bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de michaël szames est de retour parmi
nous bonjour mes quinze jours dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
cette semaine à la fin d'un faux
suspense
nicolas sarkozy est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle déclaration à
la télévision mercredi soir
l'affrontement entre candidats de
commencer les mots d'oiseaux comme
menteur ou tricheurs ont déjà volé
mauvais départ pour l'examen de la tva
sociale à l'assemblée la commission des
finances a rejeté le texte faute de
députés ump présents une boulette pour
la mesure phare du dernier collectif
budgétaire les députés de la majorité se
sont rattrapés en votant le texte dans
l'hémicycle
enfin un peu de cinéma dans cette
émission nous reviendrons sur la sortie
de la dame de fer avec meryl streep qui
incarne margaret thatcher premier
ministre britannique pendant 11 ans
puisque en 1990
la dame de fer ou le règne de
l'ultralibéralisme qui la fit haïr ou
admirait c'est selon est avec nous pour
commenter tous ces sujets et bien
d'autres bienvenue claude goasguen jeu
réputé ump de paris maire du xvième
arrondissement parisien vous faites
parti des libéraux de la majorité on
vous a beaucoup entendu ces dernières
années en souvent en désaccord avec les
méthodes du gouvernement avec françois
fillon mais aussi avec nicolas sarkozy
rassurez nous fait toujours partie de ma
note aaa puisque jamais puisque au fond
je me retrouve beaucoup mieux dans le
discours actuel de nicolas sarkozy que
dans le discours des deux premières
années c'est à dire le dernier discours
celui du figaro magazine par exemple oui
oui je trouve que là moi je suis un
libéral je trouve que la société
française est bloqué elle est bloquée
parce que les corporatismes sont trop
forts il confond j'ai presque regretter
que dans les premières années on ne
s'attaque pas d'une manière plus
vigoureuse au aux habitudes par exemple
la formation professionnelle que je
connais très bien je suis en rapport à
une vingtaine d'années sur le
financement ça n'a pas changé en réalité
la formation 30 milliards
les patrons les syndicats les régions
tout le monde est d'accord pour bien
faire un mois l'itc les chômeurs qui
paye
et qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
alors dans ses premières années de
quinquennat j'ai pour vous en tout cas
oui j'ai trouvé qu'on était pas ces
libéraux allaient première année mais le
passé loin ça n'allait pas assez loin
mais je suis très content de voir que
maintenant s'il faut recourir au
référendum
je pense que s'il faut le faire il
faudra le faire qu'à la démocratie
parlementaire française est quand même
très cette émission juste peut-être une
question sur les investitures à paris là
donc on parle des législatives vous avez
soutenu pendant un moment pendant
longtemps rachida dati j'essaie françois
fillon candidat paris c'est une mauvaise
idée
non je trouve que la méthode qui a été
employé pour envoyer fillon n'était pas
très correct à l'égard de quelqu'un vous
savez dans ce genre de chose il vaut
mieux s'arranger on trouve toujours des
arrangements on a fait ça d'une manière
un peu autoritaire je dirais presque un
peu machiste quoi les membres de charles
m entièrement
oui bon cela étant maintenant il ya les
investitures françois fillon est
quelqu'un que je soutiens je soutiendrai
moi je sais je suis je suis pas une
mentalité de dissidents quand parti a
décidé d'investir françois fillon jeudi
à rachida dati j'ai fait tout ce que
j'ai pu mais là maintenant nous n'allons
pas rentrer en dissidence pour empêcher
le président de la république a donné
les ennuis supplémentaires au président
qui en a assez la raison continue son
combat ou pas je crois pas non
franchement je crois qu'elle a tort
elle elle a un grand avenir devant elle
si elle sait de temps en temps calme et
son ardeur et je comprends un peu
qu'elle soit qu'elles soient furieuse
mais enfin vous savez la politique c'est
avaler aussi des couleuvres
on va passer à l'actualité de la semaine
lundi à l'assemblée nationale une
question évidemment tu va vous
intéresser
où sont passés les députés ump
c'est ce que l'on appelle un couac la
tva sociale annoncée il ya quelques
semaines par le président a été rejeté
en commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale
la cause est toute simple il n'y avait
pas suffisamment de députés ump pour
voter la mesure un simple retard pour la
droite une petite victoire pour la
gauche
les explications de chloé buffard je
vais suspendre la séance afin de
permettre à la commission d'achever ses
travaux a à peine commencé et déjà
retardé le débat sur la tva sociale
n'est toujours pas terminée en
commission plus de 800 amendements à
examiner
et vers 18 heures une petite victoire
pour la gauche
pardon elle vient d'être supprimée en
commission on était majoritaire
ça passe mal puisque en commission la
mesure proposée par le gouvernement a
été supprimée
et pourquoi l'ump n'est pas mobilisée
aller devant les électeurs pour se faire
réélire alors que le bilan de l'actuelle
majorité est catastrophique sur le plan
économique et social en disant c'est
nous qui avons augmenté la tva c'est
nous qui allons provoquer l'augmentation
des prix c'est nous qui allons porter la
responsabilité de la baisse de pouvoir
d'achat et en plus c'est nous qui allons
porter la responsabilité de casser la
croissance c'est pas facile à porter à
la surprise générale la commission des
finances vient de rendre un avis négatif
sur la tva sociale
les socialistes étaient en effet plus
nombreux que les députés ump le groupe
n'a pas été assez attentifs au fait que
en face au groupe socialiste
ils ont voulu faire un coup en étant
plus nombreux que nous et c'est vrai que
c'est pas très heureux à la veille de
l'annoncé de la candidature du président
un public ça je vous la corde bien
volontiers il s'agit d'un simple avis
sur la tva sociale le gouvernement
pourra passer outre et rétablir le texte
en séance
avec plus d'une heure et demie de retard
le débat commence dans l'hémicycle dans
un climat très tendu
soyez heureux soyez fiers de votre cou
qui a fait perdre une heure et demie de
débats à l'assemblée qui a fait perdre
du temps à tout le monde qui n'aura rien
apporté au schmilblick
sauf une petite satisfaction de monsieur
ayrault c'est un couac qui tombe mal
pour la majorité car nicolas sarkozy a
fait de la tva sociale une des mesures
phare de la fin de son mandat alors
claude goasguen seul texte a finalement
été votée mais est ce que c'est un acte
manqué de la part des députés ump qui ne
sont pas très favorables à cet effet
notamment c'est pas vrai ils ont voté
contre a forcé apparemment non pas
contraints et forcés suis pas une tva
sociale contrairement au moment parlé
tout à l'heure
non ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué c'est que
les socialistes au cours du week-end
sans prévenir personne et fait une
petite magouille de
de couloir ils ont fait basculer dix
personnes d'une commission sur une autre
ce qui est bon à la limite classique ce
qu'il ya des besoins bien long oui
hollande
monsieur hollande candidat à la
présidence de la république s'est permis
de jouer un petit jeu de d'arrière-cour
et d'arrière boutique du parlement je
trouvais quand même ça un peu raide et
d'ailleurs je trouve que toute cette
aventure de monsieur ayrault est assez
pitoyable mais sur le fond quand même
cette tv sur le fond cette tva n'est pas
la tva les difficultés ne sont pas très
favorables aux circonscriptions quand
vous retournez on vous dit finalement
cet hiver et en 2007 elle vous a fait
perdre quelques départs et on s'était
pas la même il faut bien comprendre
qu'en 2007
nous sommes en période d'expansion une
tva en période d'expansion vous colle de
l'inflation
là nous sommes quasiment en période de
déflation c'est à dire que au mieux s'il
ya une importance de cette tva qui est
quand même minime à multi sa part besoin
bon ça ça fera une stabilité des prix
mais certainement pas une inflation tout
le reste c'est du pipeau
d'autre part c'est pas une tva parce que
la tva normalement sa part dans les
caisses de l'état
là sa part pas dans les caisses de
l'état puisque sa part sur la baisse des
cotisations pas normal ça nous rabâche 1
franchement toutes les enquêtes sur
l'allemagne l'angleterre
toutes les évaluations sur 1,6 et puis
la taxe la taxe sur la sur les revenus
de la csg tout ça en réalité stabilisera
les prises c'est pas agréable de le
faire c'est clair qu'on aurait préféré
éviter ce genre de mesures mais très
franchement si y'a pas de quoi quand
même se rouler par terre en disant que
c'est une augmentation drastique des
appeaux quand je compare aux au
programme de monsieur hollande
je trouve qu'on est quand même très très
gentil en tout cas vous allez jouer la
discipline majoritaire après puisqu'il y
avait fait d'autres fois qu'ils font en
cours se fait partie de l'opposition si
on a fait ça quand on était en position
ce qui est choquant c'est que hollande
se s'apprêtait à ce jeu et il paraît que
c'est un peu remonté les bretelles par
françois fillon en rayant groupement du
matin allez voter en masse at il dit moi
j'ai toujours été favorable à avenches
est le graal non mais non la tva sociale
c'est pas la tva nous sommes dans une
période où on a un déficit moi je suis
pour la baisse des dépenses publiques
il ya quelque chose qui est
obsessionnelle pour un libéral c'est de
baisser les dépenses publiques en ce
gouvernement le fait ça lui donne un
point positif on aurait pu le faire plus
tôt voyez pourquoi
au début j'étais plus critique qu'à
l'arrivée
donc vous vous dites on aurait pu faire
plus tôt c'est bien sûr comme l'a dit
françois fillon dont sûr on aurait pu le
faire plus tôt je trouve que les états
européens ont été trop dépensier et qu'
on aurait dû baisser les dépenses
publiques et le budget social beaucoup
plus tôt le gérer autrement en tout cas
on retrouve le libéralisme à la fin du
quinquennat on aurait dû le trouver un
peu plus tôt mais justement c'est la
raison pour laquelle je soutiens avec
beaucoup d'ardeur nicolas sarkozy en
retour son intérêt social juste une à la
question jean marc ayrault qui propose
un référendum sur la tva sociale c'est
une rigolade leçon contrôlerait il a été
lamentable de guercif c'est un discours
qui l'honore peut aller pour plaider
fera référendum sur le tva sociale alors
que françois hollande doit de dire que
le référendum c'était épouvantable
c'est le prochain petit jeu
parlementaire petit malice parlementaire
ovadia aller puisqu'on parle référendum
mardi nicolas sarkozy rebâti sa
proposition de référendum sur les
chômeurs en ce mardi on guette les
moindres déplacements du président pas
encore candidat devant une nuée de
caméras dans l'isère nicolas sarkozy à
reparle de l'idée d'un référendum sur
les obligations des chômeurs mais parle
plutôt cette fois-ci de droit à la
formation
les ministres prennent ensuite le relais
dans l'hémicycle jérémy hartmann samedi
dans les pages du figaro magazine
cette fois ci devant les salariés de
photowatt nicolas sarkozy a décidé de
marteler sa nouvelle idée phare s'il le
faut je demanderai au peuple français
son avis sur cette question de la
formation du droit à la formation à tout
h pour ne laisser tomber personne parce
que chacun a le droit de travailler
si son champ la force plus question de
référendum sur les chômeurs les mots
sont choisis
le concept lui n'a pas changé face aux
députés dans l'hémicycle
les ministres du gouvernement assure le
service après-vente des annonces du
président candidat
l'idée est simple c'est davantage de
droits à la formation et pour qu'il y
ait bien évidemment indemnisation disons
les choses clairement
c'est une offre de formation sérieuse ou
une offre d'emploi sérieuse était refusé
est-ce que l'on continue à ne rien faire
et à ne rien dire je le dis clairement
les droits et les devoirs
est ensemble sur des sujets comme cela
il faut pas avoir peur du peuple parce
que le bon sens il a aussi toute sa
place dans un référendum pas convaincu
les députés de l'opposition dénonce une
mesure démagogique et parle de stratégie
d'enfumage nicolas sarkozy me fait
penser à ces pickpockets qui essayent
d'attirer l'attention des électeurs sur
un autre sujet que celui qui les
préoccupe pour pouvoir leur faire les
poches en l'occurrence pour pouvoir
faire les poches avec la tva sociale
pour pouvoir menacer les salaires et la
protection sociale il faut qu'ils
attirent l'attention des électeurs sur
un autre sujet si elle ne fait pas
l'unanimité
l'idée lancée par nicolas sarkozy
correspond en tout cas à sa stratégie de
campagne obligé le camp adverse à se
positionner sur ses propositions
bon claude goasguen on s'y perd un petit
peu dans ce référendum quelle est la
bonne question
la bonne question c'est un sujet ont
duré pendant ce qui vient d'être évoquée
est un sujet très important
tellement technique que les français
auront du mal à saisir exactement la
portée du système moi je c'est un sujet
que je connais parfaitement depuis 20
ans ni la gauche ni la droite n'arrive à
débloquer ce vaste barnum de 30
milliards d'euros que la formation
professionnelle questions aussi
complexes que ceux traités par un oui
c'est sûr mais mais par ce livre parce
que justement d'arriver ils sont tous
d'accord
le patronat est d'accord avec les
syndicats qui d'accord avec les régions
pour ne rien faire
en réalité cette formation elle est
exercée comme vous savez vous comme
iliad institutions de formation en
france 50 fils savez vous combien a
réellement 800 et on pouvait pas ça fait
vingt ans la loi
non on peut pas arrêter on a fait des
tas de lois elles ne sont pas appliquées
parce que tout le monde se retrouve
autour de la table c'est exactement ce
que nicolas sarkozy a décrit dans son
meeting en disant c'est le consensus
pour garder ne nous en mettons pas le
rapport perruches aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
va tout à fait dans les deux sens je
vous assure c'est une question très
importante dont les chômeurs seront
bénéficiaires parce que cette formation
elle doit servir en priorité à eux alors
c'est pas le cas concrètes vous avez
institut formé par décès quelques
questions en même temps quelles
questions vous mettons dont on
exactement exactement la question qui
vient d'être posée comment se fera la
réforme de leur remettra un article de
loi avec la manière dont se fera
l'indemnisation des chômeurs
le droit à la formation et le fait
d'avoir une formation prioritaire pour
les chômeurs qui soit qualifiante et qui
permettent d'avoir un emploi donc c'est
une façon de ne pas passer par les
syndicats mais c'est une façon de casser
ce consensus social mou qui nous tuent
depuis une vingtaine d'années
malheureusement on y est obligé mais je
crois que c'est l'intérêt du peuple que
de voter ce que l'adolescente
c'est ce que nicolas sarkozy a appelé le
blocage c'est un blocage mais bien sûr
que c'est un blocage c'est qu'avec les
syndicats un peu plus négocier c'est pas
seulement les syndicats le patronat les
experts les professeurs les instituts
l'argent coule à flot dans cette
histoire et on fait n'importe quoi avec
7 e place pour la négociation mais et
alors la gauche d'ailleurs je remercie
la gauche elle avait repris mon rapport
à l'époque parce que je l'avais fait en
93 sont cassés les dents pareil vous
tombez là dans un mur d'indifférence et
de dorures et vous faites toutes les
commissions d enquête de la terre vous
n'y arrivez pas parce que c'est très
complexe vous avez des organismes
collecteurs les régions tous non de
rentrer en concurrence
et finalement il ya 10% de l'argent de
la formation professionnelle seulement
qui penche alors l'idée du référendum
est tout à fait à la main françois
fillon en a proposé un mardi encore en
réunion mais beaucoup sur la règle d'or
budgétaire
vous êtes d'accord moi je suis d'accord
à mon avis si la gauche est minoritaire
je vois pas comment il pourrait éviter
elle même de voter la règle d'or
puisqu'elle l'a proposé donc vous savez
qu'on fait référence au oui non mais je
vois pas comment les sénateurs pourrait
refuser la règle d'or puisque france ils
ont refusé pour le moment parce qu'on
est avant l'élection mais imaginons que
nous sommes après l'élection nicolas
sarkozy est président il appelle le
congrès est ce que les socialistes vont
prendre le risque de ne pas tenir les
engagements qu'il avait tenus avant
inutile de dire s'il faut faire un
référendum sur la gaude on le fera mais
là je pense que sur le congrès on peut
passer qui pourraient se poser c'est pas
traités européens
le référendum deviendrait une arme un
peu usuelle pour pour toute situation de
compte il n'ya pas voilà quand il n'y a
pas de solution je vous assure c'est pas
un vain mot de dire qu'il ya des
blocages dans la société française
crozier elle disait j'ai la trentaine
appeler ça la société bloquée il faut la
débloquer ce qu'on va devenir un petit
peu comme la suisse c'est à dire qu'on
va gouverner de référents gamme au
référendum a fait pareil c'est pas mais
il ya une vraie réflexion à mener sur la
démocratie parlementaire
il ya une vraie des réflexions cirque
clown n'ya plus démocratique il y avait
pour moi la démocratie parlementaire il
faut la chercher à la loupe
quand même hein on est plutôt dans un
système présidentiel quasi monarchique
et bien je vous demande également une
plainte de l'opposition j'ai toujours
été dans cette ligne chemin
oui je suis encore libéral têtu
impénitent mais je trouve que par les
temps qui courent avec la montée du
populisme qui frappe à cause de la crise
il faut donner la parole au peuple car
le peuple ne se sentent plus représentés
par les élites il ya des moments où
quand il ya des blocages bien il faut
que le peuple choisisse même un homme de
gauche devraient pouvoir dire ça ordonné
l'abandon le disent pas redonner la
parole au peuple c'est pas populiste
si c'est la manière d'associer le puck
comme l'avait fait le général de gaulle
à des décisions qui étaient cantonnés à
des élites quand le général de gaulle a
proposé l'élection au suffrage universel
du président de la république en
laquelle on l'accusé de tout dictateur
populiste et cetera plus personne
aujourd'hui ne remet en cause cette
élection au suffrage universel mais
c'était un appel au peuple contre les
grands notables qui faisait quinze tours
16 tours 17 tours sur la quatrième
république alors vous parlez des
parlementaires voilà un sujet qui va
vous intéresser et qui intéresse tous
les parlementaires et qui d'une certaine
façon transcende les clivages politiques
le cumul entre un mandat électif et un
mandat exécutif aujourd'hui on peut être
député ou sénateur ou mer et siégé dans
une communauté de communes une
opportunité largement utilisée par la
majorité des parlementaires rapport du
sénat a rendu ce mardi entreprend de
dire quelques vérités
les propos de sandra cerqueira voilà un
sujet qui dépasse le clivage politique
habituelle un ump et un ps ensemble
auteur d'un rapport sur le cumul des
mandats des parlementaires
aujourd'hui on peut être député ou
sénateur et maire et siégé dans une
communauté de communes trois fonctions
chronophage influente aussi certains
parlementaires cumulent jusqu'à quatre
mandats et finissent par ne plus siéger
dans l'hémicycle
et si vous devez rajouter qu au titre de
ses fonctions vous occupez aussi des
responsabilités dans des organismes type
gestion d'hôpitaux ou de maisons de
retraite ou d'organismes le syndicat des
hauts de seine de construction la vie
devient tout simplement impossible
d'autant que cumuler trois emplois du
temps veut aussi dire cumulé trois
salaires un sénateur qui est maire d'une
ville de plus de 100000 habitants
gagnent environ 8000 euros mensuels
auxquels s'ajoutent près de 4000 euros
quand l'élu président une grosse
communauté urbaine soit au total douze
mille euros pour les français c'est pas
tant le cumul des mandats parce qu'ils
aiment bien avoir des élus cuisant ce
qui souvent les met en colère ou attire
des remarques ou des critiques acerbes
c'est le cumul des salaires depuis 1992
les indemnités des parlementaires sont
limitées à huit mille 100 euros mais la
loi prévoit un dispositif de reversement
une pratique curieuse qui permet à tout
élu qui dépasse le plafond de désigner
un collègue pour lui reverser le
trop-plein perçu alors si vous deviez
choisir claude goasguen est ce que vous
garderiez votre votre les deux d'accord
vous choisiriez donc pas autres députés
et les sénateurs commet une erreur
les parlementaires n'ont pas de salaire
ils ont des indemnités les indemnités
sont écrêter les crêtes mans
n'appartient plus dans la plupart des
cas aux parlementaires c'est la
collectivité territoriale auquel il
appartient qui répartit cet écrêtement
en fonction d'ailleurs à paris ça fait
quelques problèmes de de la majorité la
faune est ce qu'il faudrait pas que la
faute et on est placé indemnités on est
plafonnée et on est déjà plafonné
l'écrêtement cesser le plafond peut pas
aller au delà ce que je trouve en
revanche qui fait la vraie question
c'est là pourquoi est ce que au fond le
cumul et existe en france et pas
ailleurs
il faut limiter ces sur trois ou quatre
mandats c'est absurde 2 parce que
l'administration est toute puissante
très franchement moi je suis maire
d'arrondissement si je suis pas député
mais monsieur delanoë me passe sous les
fourches caudines déjà toute la journée
mais là c'est plus la peine que j'exerce
mon fonctions de maire d'arrondissement
comme vous pourriez pas ça veut dire que
moi je suis contre je veux bien vous
il n'y a pas assez de pouvoir moi je
veux que l'administration puisse céder
devant l'élu or malheureusement le cumul
des mandats demeure parce que
l'administration est puissante si vous
n'êtes pas à paris pour défendre notre
bifteck et que vous être maire c'est
pour ça que de l'annuaire commis une
grave erreur en étant pas d'ailleurs
parlementaire ça a beaucoup pâti à paris
il faut être avec le gouvernement contre
le gouvernement suivre le gouvernant ne
pas lâcher le gouvernement c'est
malheureusement le style français
mission veut changer effectivement ce
style en décentralisant donnant plus de
france j'ai lu je suis tout à fait
d'accord probable que le non cumul doit
s'accompagner d'une réforme bien sûr
bien sûr être un gros chantier
on va passer au mercredi avec le temps
fort de la semaine je crois qu'on peut
l'appeler comme ça à nicolas sarkozy qui
met fin à un long suspense le président
a choisi le décor d'un journal télévisé
de 20h celui de tf1 pour annoncer sa
candidature un wiki il présente un peu
comme une obligation ne pas se présenter
sera dit il comme un abandon de poste
sans écoute oui je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
et donc si j'ai décidé d'être candidat à
c'est parce que j'ai des choses à dire
aux français
j'ai des propositions et leur faire et
que les changements que nous avons
engagées dans les cinq années qui
viennent il faut que les français
comprennent que la question essentielle
qui est posée c'est celle que si la
france est forte
ils seront protégés alors le président
s'est dit soulagé d'entrer en campagne
vos six mois je pensais qu'il allait
rentrer un peu plus tard en campagne ils
voulaient en découdre parce que je crois
qu'il en avait assez de prendre des
coups sans pouvoir rendre est bon on a
vu d'ailleurs après que le candidat
n'est pas le même que le président très
bien c'est un très bon candidat
bon c'est une c'est une annonce qu'il a
dont il a jugé utile d'avancer la date
pourquoi il arrête je crois qu'il avait
envie de d'expliquer de d'en découdre
quoi s'est il avait envie d'en avoir
assez de superman n'est pas une question
la stratégie produit aussi sûrement il
faut rattraper le retard enfin tout ça
c'est une grand communiquant les grosses
têtes qui étudient des sondages
je crois que l'internement éthique aussi
oui mais enfin vous savez quand un
tempérament comme sarkozy c'est un
tempérament de combattants quelqu'un qui
se laisse pas marcher sur les pieds
comme ça et on l'a vu d'ailleurs
immédiatement après mais au soleil tant
sur le plan on aurait pu imaginer qu'il
le prenne un peu plus tard cette posture
de candidat mitterrand l'avait fait le
22 mars c'est à dire leur au dernier
moment
c'est un choix je crois qu'il s'agira 15
février
il veut il veut aller dans l'arène il a
des choses à dire au peuple et vous le
connaissez bien vous avez pas eu
l'impression lors de cette interview
qu'il a donnée sur téléphone qu'il avait
plus une question de devoir que dans vie
non content parce que je le connais bien
c'est il adore ça c'est un homme de
meetings c'est un orateur exceptionnel
c'est un débatteur il est il est comme
dirai comment dire c'est comme astérix à
il est tombé dans la potion magique à la
politique c'est sa vie il a beau dire
que éventuellement s'il est battu et
quittera la politique je suis un petit
mot nettoyer leurs comptes non je crois
pas s'il est battu vous pensez qu'il
continuera oui bien sûr ce truc
combattants ce quelqu'un qui est qui vit
la politique par toutes les pores de la
peau je vous dis date sa potion magique
à lui c'est la politique et une vie
politique après la présidence ou et sur
mon sofa et les jeunes ya 57 ans quand
même si on ya de quoi faire à 50 ans et
serait quoi ce serait par exemple être
candidat en 2017 si jamais il était
témoin je pense qu'il va être élu ça
c'est autre chose mais c'est un homme
qui ne détonnera pas comme ça de la
politique française sicile et ses
opposants le croient ils se trompent
totalement il leur donnera une leçon
quand même qui méritera d'être entendu
vous parlez les communicants tout à
l'heure que la doyenne nous est sans
doute vu la fiche qui l'ont choisi pour
lui vous vous la trouvez comment on
allait souvent je suis pas compétent
qu'un juriste borné slogans contre celle
de valéry giscard d'estaing a nommé
ouais c'est pas vraiment la meilleure
année
mais ils ont choisi ont choisi jeudi ce
sont eux qui sont les compétents pas moi
enfin campagne pour nicolas sarkozy
france forte chance juste france tout ce
qu'on veut mais surtout éviter nous la
france de hollande mais vu les sondages
il le changement c'est maintenant c'est
pas vraiment non plus du team génial
franchement maintenant avec ça vous
pouvez vendre des spaghettis j'ai fait
ça a été rapide quand même sur sur les
sauvages jamais un candidat était partie
dossier lourd est-ce qu'ils y croyaient
vraiment même si oui que vous pensez que
nicolas sarkozy pourrait être candidat
et ça te ment et lui est ce que vous
pensez
aujourd'hui qu'il a encore ses chances
du oui les sondages on voit bien que la
cristallisation se fait ça mais il ya
six mois nicolas sarkozy était même pas
sûrs d'être au deuxième tour
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la
cristallisation se fait entre les
socialistes et lui et que a priori il ya
deux trois points peut-être à reprendre
2 3 pas plus de trois et ça donnera une
élection comme d'habitude et d'élections
très serrées entre la gauche et la
droite c'est clair arrivé même si
sarkozy ne s'adresse pas la droite ça
aura quand même la signification pour
les commentateurs de l'affrontement
classique
giscard chirac mitterrand et les autres
en font ça fera du 51 49
mais je sais pas encore dans quel sens
faire claude goasguen vous imaginez
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de réactions à
cette annonce de candidature de nicolas
sarkozy on va les écouter et aurait agi
juste après nicolas sarkozy cherche à
faire oublier son bilan qui est
dramatique il faut le dire en matière de
chômage d'effondrement du pouvoir
d'achat de l'augmentation de
l'insécurité d'explosion de
l'immigration mais
je les trouvais assez insincère et
probablement pas convaincu lui-même de
pouvoir faire oublier aux français les
échecs très lourd qui ont été ceux de
son quinquennat
ce soir nous avons assisté à un numéro
de pur cynisme de la part de quelqu'un
qui vient nous parler de ses ambitions
sociales après avoir fait reculer le
pays comme aucun autre président ne
l'avait fait de toute la vème république
cet homme là c'est celui qui vous a pris
la retraite à 60 ans n'oubliez jamais
puisqu'il a choisi lui-même l'expression
de capitaine sur un bateau lorsqu'un
capitaine a mené un bateau jusque là
situation nous sommes sur les récifs et
est dans la situation d'un bateau échoué
bien il faut changer des critiques bien
sûr un françois hollande lui était au
même moment meeting à rouen mercredi
soir dans un difficile exercice
d'équilibriste minimisé l'annoncé de
candidature de son adversaire sans la
passer sous silence
il en a même beaucoup parler chloé
buffard et jean baptiste daoulas et n
sur place jusqu'au bout françois
hollande aura tout fait pour minimiser
la déclaration de nicolas sarkozy comme
prévu meeting à rouen sa ville natale
devant près de dix mille personnes
le socialiste multiplie les attaques
contre nicolas sarkozy avec son arme
préférée plus moore
vous connaissez la nouvelle du jour
peut-être n'at-elle pas venu jusqu'à
vent le président candidat est désormais
candidat président
mais je vais vous faire une confidence
moi je m'en doutais pendant une martèle
ses valeurs vérité travail justice comme
au bourget il attaque la finance qu'il
entend dominer et il ironise sur les
référendum proposé par nicolas sarkozy
et j'ai même trouvé la question qui sera
posée à nos concitoyens
voulez-vous poursuivre cinq ans de plus
avec le même président voulez vous
changer de président de politique de
méthodes de majorité
le référendum qui va arriver le 6 mai
françois hollande affirmé vouloir
poursuivre sa route sans regarder à
droite
mais dès ce soir le duel à distance se
poursuit il sera sur tf1 nicolas sarkozy
lui au meeting à annecy chacun son tour
pour réagir à cette entrée en campagne a
eu que françois hollande est là prenez
un petit peu le mode de l'humour pour
réaliser moi je fais prendre de l'humour
pour françois hollande
figurez-vous que françois hollande a des
idées moi moi personnellement je ne le
savais pas je ne savais pas qu'il y
avait des idées pas qu'il ya des idées
ils voudraient ils devraient les
exprimer il devrait pas à manier comme
ça à l'humour vous savez françois
hollande
à croire que tout est facile dans la vie
politique il est président de corrèze
il a donné son som truc son petit
bourget puis crois que personne ne va
l'attaquer personne ne va dire la vérité
aux français quelle plaisir la
république est en train d'accrocher les
pas contents mais voilà quand on n'a pas
d'idée
eh bien on essaye d'en trouver pour le
moment je ne vois aucune idée si j'en
vois que deux jambes à 3 1
l'impôt de l'impôt 3 l'impôt voilà la
solution miracle de françois hollande
très franchement si c'est ça qu'il
appelle des idées un trail va falloir
qu'ils cherchent autre chose et bella
bellow demain justement en meeting
nicolas sarkozy ou même françois
hollande sur tf1 on a senti que le ton
était monté d'un cran
je sais bien c'est très bien parce qu'on
voit bien quelle quasiment parler de
moteurs pour françois hollande ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que vettel
hollande et sarkozy ne se cite pas tout
en citant ces l'inculpation pour nous on
a tout compris
bon mais c'est la logique politique
coûte est folle
nicolas sarkozy ça fait des années que
les socialistes à l'assemblée de la
pisse contre nicolas sarkozy qui est un
imbécile
c'est quelqu'un qui se trompe il ne
connaît rien il a des seniors sa fille
ça fait du bien aux landes de temps en
temps de se faire rafraîchir s'est fait
rafraîchir il ne prend pas bien
d'ailleurs
il a un humour c'est assez grinçant
parce que je les trouvais très mauvais
hier soir dans sa réaction était presque
déstabiliser c'est le jeu de rôle c'est
de ne plus rien dit
de se dire en tout je dis plus rien
comme ça il n'arrivera rien on continuer
ça va pas se passer comme ça là c'est
pour ça que je crois qu'il se complétant
un nouveau ton du côté de l'ump ce
n'était pas le cas il ya quelques 120
écouter n'étiez pas à non maintenant le
nouveau ton moi moi je fais plusieurs
débats et social en panne ah oui on est
rentrés les socialistes nous l'hérault
des murs en fait plein la tête
depuis plusieurs semaines il de la piste
l'italo maintenant ils seraient ils se
rendre compte qu'en réalité il ya une
mobilisation de l'ump et on le croyait
pas quand même qu'avec le nombre
d'adhérents kona avec les structures de
partis conan on va rester comme ça
l'armé au pied à écouter toute la
journée monsieur hollande parler de la
la société du rêve qu'ils nous proposent
tout ça il faudra sortir de la bleuette
ça dans une campagne qui s'annonce dure
à c'est une campagne qui s'annonce
sévère parce que la conséquence de tout
ça pour les français va être extrêmement
sévères
c'est pas du tout le même type de
société coller des impôts aux gens faire
de la dépense publique faire voter les
étrangers aux élections locales ce sont
des choix grave donc de notre devoir de
dire attention des campagnes les plus
dures
ok oui oui c'est une conquête un peu de
moi en tout cas c'est une campagne qui
est difficile j'espère que nicolas
sarkozy va avoir
je sens d'ailleurs d'un peu dans les
sondages un frémissement que ça va
pouvoir se normaliser mais comme je
connais la gauche qui a un côté tartuffe
quand même extraordinaire ils vont être
odieux odieux et elles sont odieux
depuis cinq ans mais on répondra
répondra on répondra coup pour coup très
franchement moi je préférais ça soit un
débat qui soit un débat sera mais tous
les adversaires que je rencontre dans
les débats ne nous en ont pas l'humour
gentille et de monsieur laurent d'un il
tape très fort puis surtout ce qui
m'agace manger les socialistes c'est ce
côté tartuffe quoi hein
bien sûr ils sont vertueux on a un élu
socialiste par jour qui est foutu un
examen et qui se retrouve quasiment
devant le tribunal mais on n'en parle
jamais ce sont bien entendu les gens de
droite qui ne sont pas vertueux comme je
le disais la campagne très dure
on va on va débusquer les tartuffes pas
c'est un autre sujet c'est un habitué
des dérapages mais cette fois c'est un
député ump dont on va parler christian
vanneste il récidive et déclenche à
nouveau une tempête en cause ses propos
niant la déportation des homosexuels
français durant la seconde guerre
mondiale il devrait être exclu de l'ump
la semaine prochaine les explications de
thomas souliers la vidéo a été postée
vendredi sur ce site d'une association
chrétienne liberté politique thème de
l'interview la famille et
l'homosexualité un sujet sur lequel clés
sont vanessa déjà dérapé à plusieurs
reprises cette fois ci il donne sa
version de l'histoire
la fameuse légende de la déportation des
homosexuels
il faut être très clair là aussi en
allemagne il ya eu une répression des
homosexuels et la déportation qui a
conduit à peu près à 30000 déporté il
n'y en a pas eu
ailleurs et notamment en dehors des
trois départements à l'excès il n'y a
pas eu de déportation homosexuelle en
france
une version contestée par les historiens
notamment par mickaël bertrand
dans son ouvrage référence ils avancent
le chiffre de 60 de déportés homosexuels
français
mais au-delà des chiffres c'est la
polémique qui embarrasse la droite
la condamnation est quasi unanime en
politique on ne peut pas dépasser
ensemble de bornes il a tenu une fois de
plus des propos ignobles et notre
famille politique pour va tirer toutes
les conséquences de ses propos jean
françois copé a tranché christian
vanneste ne pourra pas se présenter sous
l'étiquette ump pour les prochaines
élections législatives et le parti
pourrait même l'exclure la faute à qui
au lobby homosexuel selon le député du
nord qui persiste et signe
ce lobby d'une puissance absolument
terrifiante les terrifiantes terrifiante
cc c'est vraiment ce sont des gens
souvent des adversaires dangereux de le
maintenir
christian vanneste sera-t-il candidat
sans étiquette en juin prochain
le député n'a pas encore pris sa
décision le cas van est sera examiné
mercredi prochain lors d'un bureau
politique de l'ump a la pression mais ce
n'est pas à son coup d'essai il avait
déjà tenu des propos en 2006 en 2010
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir exclue bien
avant
côté on l'a suspendu il a il s'était un
peu calmée là maintenant c'est fini il
faut exclure
c'est vraiment ce qu'il a dit est
inadmissible c'est inadmissible c'est du
négationnisme quand bien même il y
aurait eu qu'un seul homosexuel qui
étaient en camp de concentration parce
qu'il était homosexuel
quand bien même ce ne veut pas en france
mais en allemagne en tchécoslovaquie
n'importe où ce qu'a dit monsieur
vanneste
ici pas de m enfin pas mal qui est pas
un mot de ce point de vue pour dire
c'est vrai que les chiffres sont
contestés mais rien de plus himmler pas
de lumière quand même tout d'un coup
lubie contre les homosexuels
mais c'est gravissime c'est du
négationnisme c'est épouvantable je suis
très choqué et je ne fais pas partie du
logo du lobby homosexuel je le dis tout
de suite
servane s d'auby parce que je trouvais
ça alors ça c'est le pompon c'est
tellement évident peut-être situer ce
qu'il a dit à propos justement de ce
lobby l'a dit que l'ump était sous
influence médiatique du logo du lobby
officiel
pour moi c'est que je ne suis pas sous
l'influencé du lobby homosexuel je suis
contre le mariage homosexuel je suis
contre l'adoption mais très franchement
quand j'entends ça c'est pas un problème
d'homosexuels c'est un problème que
c'est ça me paraît complètement
incohérent scandaleux et par conséquent
il n'a plus rien à faire à l'ump c'est
clair il fait partie de cette frange dit
droite populaire est ce qu'elle pose
problème cette droite populaire aile qui
veut couper le cordon
sanitaires nationales oui elle pose
problème quand elle a déjà comme la nes
mais il ya des types très bien là dans
les types qui sont tout à fait corrects
qui ont une vision de la politique qui
n'est pas sale et l'ump c'est une grande
famille
il ya tous des libéraux des des quasi
populiste des gaullistes des démocrates
chrétiens
bon c'est leur truc moi j'ai rien contre
le moment je suis pas d'accord avec eux
ya des moments je suis proche mais bon à
partir du moment où on reste quand même
dans la norme générale jeudi à une
société civilisée
elle va passer au jeudi avec un conseil
constitutionnel qui se penche sur le
problème des parrainages
ils sont trois candidats avoir demandé
au conseil constitutionnel de trancher
sur la question de l'anonymat des
parrainages marine le pen corinne lepage
et christine boutin même si elle n'est
plus candidate
les audiences ont lieu ce jeudi matin
l'occasion d'avancer ses arguments pu
voir si je suis ici aujourd'hui si j'ai
saisi le conseil d'état si j'ai saisi le
conseil constitutionnel
ça n'est pas pour défendre marine le pen
il faut bien en être conscient c'est
pour défendre la démocratie française
c'est pour défendre les millions de
français dont je considère qu'ils ont le
droit de pouvoir voter pour qui bon leur
semble et pas pour les candidats que
l'ump et le ps aurait choisi pour eux je
ne soutiens pas la démarche de marine le
pen je soutiens la démocratie qui est
fragilisé et qui est en danger
et tant mieux si nous sommes plusieurs à
le dénoncer le système est aujourd'hui
bloquée ça c'est une certitude
claude goasguen nous est tanné lieu ce
qu' il faut il faut établir l'anonymat
pour les parrainages
arrivera avant ces signatures dont une
au fond le même cinéma cette foire est
qu un ouvrage pas du tout je pas du tout
convaincu alors que marine le pen nous
donne des leçons de démocratie quand ça
fait sourire c'est la loi c'est la loi
elle est comme ça on m'attend pas ce que
va décider le conséquences sociales
m'écouter très franchement je préfère un
très mauvais juriste mais enfin j'ai
quelques connaissances
il m'étonnerait que conseil
constitutionnel invalide une loi
électorale aussi fondamental que celle
qui a été voté en toute continuité en
toute sérénité on a fléchi à plus long
terme parce que finalement on peut
réfléchir de tous il faut il faut non il
faut que non non pourquoi denis m'a
écouté chacun prend ses responsabilités
enfin on a si ça continue il va falloir
qu'on se croit obligé de donner pour que
les gens existe quelque chose qu'on ne
pense pas non la démocratie c'est pas ça
moi je suis allé lui je donne mon
parrainage qui je veux bien je crois pas
me forcer la main en disant vous allez
prêter là ils doivent et qui ce succès
magourou et aiderait pas mais un maire
éventuellement maire sait ce qu'il veut
franchement s'il donne son son
parrainage à marine le pen j'ai rien
contre lui mais prend ses
responsabilités à il assume
c'est un choix politique importante on
peut pas vouloir tout et le contraire de
tout ce qu'on a mis là là on enlevait
l'anonymat est parti comment et pas une
consigne de la part des partis je vais
redire absolument pas on a empêché
personne de donner le parrainage moi je
ne donnerai pas mon parrainage il ya
marine le pen ya madame boutin qui
d'ailleurs s'est retiré je donnerai le
parrainage à qui je veux donner le
parrainage c'est à dire à nicolas
sarkozy d'avoir eu des pressions radi si
vous voulez votre financement sur tel
projet cela démontre en tout cas ça peut
être un peu non ne croyez pas non
franchement c'est peut-être possible
enfin tu sais ça c'est ridicule parce
que de toute façon une personne qui veut
donner son parrainage il le donne
je crois que madame le pen droit c'est
pareil chez les as pas les a pas si elle
les a les noms d'elie de démocratie de
5,6 déni de démocratie ton franchement
c'est la loi on va pas changer la loi
parce que tel ou tel candidat a du mal à
trouver
d'ailleurs pourquoi est ce que les gens
ne veulent pas donner leur signature à
marine le pen
pourquoi c'est ça la vraie question
parce que marine le pen n'arrête pas de
baver sur les élus en disant qu'ils sont
tous des voyous qu'ils ont tous la main
dans la main dans le pot de confiture et
ses près de 7 tonnes
les élus se disent de après tout
débrouillez vous 1 on peut pas à la fois
dire que la démocratie c'était
épouvantable et que les élus sont tous
les voyous corrompu et puis en même
temps aller leur dire écouter et essayer
de signer parce que ça c'est la
démocratie qu'on se débrouille quoi
c'est tout le golfe si ce que vous
pensez de la démarche de françois bayrou
qui est prêt à mettre autour de la table
de faire la concertation avec les autres
candidats pour remettre à marine le pen
d'avoir fait signature je la comprends
pas j'aime beaucoup françois bayrou qui
est un ami personnel j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé pour lui je crois que là il
s'est trompé
ça ne se fait pas on fait pas ça on
comprend pas se mettre autour de la
table en disant tiens mais moi j'en fils
51 presse le cycle usine autres
candidats alors là pour le coup là c'est
vraiment donner à la vie politique
une image je pense que françois là c'est
tromper là d'une stratégie pour
récupérer quelques voix c'est possible
ça c'est pas possible je le disais pas
puisque vous le dit c'est une question
c'est possible qu'il ait eu ça derrière
la tête
c'est possible en tout cas me l'a pas
dit mais en tout cas ça ne se fait pas
sa frappe alors que glasgow droit finir
cette émission avec un film qui sort
cette semaine sur vos écrans
vous le libéral vous avez parlé beaucoup
de votre côté libéral dans cette
émission
eh bien vous ne resterez peut-être pas
insensible à ce film la dame de fer qui
retrace la vie de margaret thatcher
simon barbarie 22 ans après son départ
de downing street la dame de fer est de
retour mais sur les écrans le parcours
de l'ancien premier ministre aujourd'hui
atteintes par la maladie d'alzheimer
redonne une seconde jeunesse à celle qui
a marqué la société britannique dans les
années 80 privatisation réduction de la
dette coupes budgétaires célébration de
l'argent était à l'époque sa marque de
fabrique des thèmes porteurs pour la
droite et une partie de la social
démocratie européenne
le retour en grâce des années thatcher
fait des nostalgiques les britanniques
comprennent que les politiques de la
dame de fer était nécessaire sur le long
terme
en dehors de la gauche du parti
travailliste le consensus balaye toute
la classe politique jusqu'en argentine
là bas le long métrage fait partie des
films les plus vus le week-end dernier
la guerre des malouines fit pourtant
plus de 600 morts dans les rangs
argentins
alors que l'om est ce que vous irez voir
ce film ouija moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer margaret thatcher avec
jacques chirac dans un entretien assez
long où elle n'avait dit elle nous avait
dit tout le mal qu'elle pensait de
jacques delors
elle est proscrite et accueille elle
était terriblement libéral terriblement
rien énergique et surtout elle détestait
le caractère bureaucratique que l'europe
était en train de prendre
elle nous avait fait une sortie terrible
là dessus elle aimait beaucoup jacques
chirac avec qui elle s'entendait très
bien et c'est une femme assez
exceptionnelle qu'elle avait raison
avant tout le monde notamment sur le
côté de la dette on ne dépense pas plus
que les raisons évidemment que les états
européens et la france y compris
d'ailleurs se sont mis à dépenser comme
des fous et maintenant évidemment paie
l'addition le monde n'est plus le même
l'europe continue à dépenser comme s'il
n'y avait pas de chine s'ils avaient pas
d'un des six avait pas de des pays
émergents qui eux sont riches créatifs
etc
quand même énormément détracteurs sur sa
politique un an son cadet l'a été du
zèle a été dur c'était composition quand
même des services publics dans la santé
oui oui gestation sur la patience et des
syndicats
mais l'angleterre l'angleterre est un
pays différent du nôtre c'est un pays
extrêmement civique et ils ont apprécié
margaret thatcher même si il après les
travaillistes ont un peu remédier c'est
vrai qu'il ya des défauts en angleterre
qui sont incontestables mais en tout cas
je peux vous dire que margaret thatcher
avait trouvé le pays dans un état
épouvantable bien à venir le libéralisme
ce logo oui parce que le libéralisme n'a
jamais existé en france encore ce serait
peut-être temps qu'un jour quand on dit
moins de dépenses publiques
pas de dette publique essayons de gérer
au mieux le budget social intelligemment
de manière à ce que les prestations
soient meilleures garanties par la
concurrence et cetera
ça c'est du libéralisme au fond jeu pour
terminer je trouve que nicolas sarkozy
est en train peut-être d'opérer dans son
discours la vraie rupture qu'on n'a pas
pu faire dans les cinq dernières années
l'époque est à la rupture en tout cas il
faut que la france change en profondeur
ça fait 30 ans que nous tournons autour
du pot sur un système qui est un système
qui tourne en rond
alors que nos voisins allemands
notamment fait grâce à schoder
d'ailleurs et angela merkel à une
révolution qui leur permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir une stabilité mondiale
aujourd'hui nous envions même si c'est
embêtant pour un français de dire que au
fond on envie l'allemagne il faudra le
courage de le dire
et moi je pense que nous avons été
retenus sans doute par une grande
timidité gouvernementale excessive mais
c'est blocage dure depuis temps
en réalité depuis la société bloquée de
michel crozier on n'a pas beaucoup
évolué et il serait peut-être temps
qu'on chante voilà beaucoup de
référendum l'appel au libéralisme de
claude goasguen merci d'avoir participé
à notre émission merci vous dit on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
bonne fin de journée à vous tous merci